saludos
la revolución empezó con un celular esto
eran los titulares que se escuchaban
para el año 2010 cuando hartos de
corrupción y de opresión en el medio
oeste los jóvenes se fueron a las redes
sociales para externar su preocupación
por lo que estaba ocurriendo en ese
entonces en esa región y la revuelta que
le siguió al denominado art spring se
propagó como fuego en un bosque seco en
esa región empezó toda una revolución
usando teléfonos celulares
y teléfonos celulares esos mismos
aparatos que tenemos en el día de hoy
donde lo conectamos a internet tratando
de buscar la selphy perfecta sacando el
piquito locución lo que kardashian
etcétera además algunas personas también
la usan para espiar a sus exparejas
todos hemos pasado por eso a ver con
quién está si la pareja 9 más vamos o
que 1 etcétera etcétera etcétera pero en
algún momento pasamos por esto sin
embargo sin embargo y volviendo al tema
uno se pregunta un teléfono móvil para
empezar una revolución por redes
sociales eso a mí me emprendió un
bombillito me hizo eso fue un momento de
eso cuando tú oyes los ángeles y por
favor no piensen que yo les viene a
hablar de política no no no fue de eso
que viene a hablar pero medir el poder
que tiene una sola persona
en el que las ideas florezcan y poder
expresarlas libremente en redes sociales
esa habilidad directa de poder crear
algo más grande que nosotros es un
impacto bastante amen
me sembró una semillita en el cerebro y
se me quedó ahí y de hecho en estos
últimos dos años yo me encuentro un poco
sorpresivo cuando a mi título cuando me
van a presentar en algún sitio le han
agregado activista político porque yo
digo ven acá y cuando fue eso mi mismo
qué pasó ahí cuál fue el camino que tú
escogiste como cómo llegamos a esto y es
sencillo señores yo no soy un activista
político nunca nunca he sido un
activista político yo lo único que soy
es una persona que ama a su país
orgulloso de ser dominicano orgulloso de
mi bandera tricolor
y uno se pregunta está mal que uno se
preocupe por lo que uno ama eso es
importante que uno se haga esa pregunta
ustedes no se imaginan lo bien que yo me
siento cada vez que yo visito el país
lo hago muy frecuentemente porque hace
cuatro años yo me mudé a atlanta mejor
que primero le hace me casé con mi bella
esposa gaby hemos emprendido unos
cuantos negocios por allá estas caritas
que ustedes ven aquí ha sido producto de
todas esas horas largas de todo el
esfuerzo que estamos poniendo ante todo
lo que estamos allá haciendo allá sin
embargo hemos estado trabajando y a la
par he estado desarrollando otros
proyectos gracias a dios y dios mediante
eso va a producir algún tipo de frutos
en estos días sin embargo desde el
momento que yo me fui de mi país sentí
que me estaba llamando mi tierra
y sentí me comenzó a provocar un
sentimiento de nostalgia el hecho de que
yo no estaba aquí en el país siempre me
hacen falta mi familia mis amigos los
fines de semana en la montaña la playa
ese calorcito que yo le puedo decir
algunos de ustedes han vivido fuera
algunos de ustedes son extranjeros pero
que se experimenta solamente aquí en
república dominicana porque es un
calorcito dominicano de la gente
dominicana que solo tenemos nosotros hay
una canción que reza dicen por ahí que
las distancias al olvido en no es así
que va el tono pero dicen que la
distancia es el olvido sin embargo a mí
no me que me causó olvido el hecho de
que yo esté lejos de mi país todo lo
contrario a mí me creció el corazón
también el corazón creo que se me puso
un poco más inteligente porque me hizo
colocar una lupa sobre nuestro país
y preocuparme por aquellas cosas que
agobian el día a día a los dominicanos a
nuestra gente
los escándalos de corrupción continúan
surgiendo a nivel mundial esto no es un
secreto para nadie y latinoamérica es
una de las regiones más afectadas por
este mal y república dominicana
desafortunadamente está compitiendo en
el lugar número 22 en el mundo de
acuerdo con el informe de la
competitividad global publicado por el
foro económico mundial muy lamentable
número 22 en el mundo
hace unos años éramos famosos aquí en
república dominicana por tener las
mejores playas del caribe el merengue la
bachata la gente más amable servicial y
cuando describían la república
dominicana siempre decían ah no el
paraíso dominican republic está gris
siempre siempre siempre y saben que yo
creo que todavía no nos podemos referir
a la república dominicana de esa forma
porque nuestra geografía sigue siendo
una hermosa tierra nuestra gente sigue
siendo amable servicial pero poco a poco
está cambiando esa idea
de quienes somos ante los ojos del mundo
avisos de potencias mundiales que
advierten a sus ciudadanos de tener
mucho cuidado de visitar nuestro país
como lo hizo recientemente el
departamento de estado de los eeuu
cuando advierte a sus ciudadanos de la
delincuencia que tenemos aquí en nuestro
país al visitar esta bella tierra para
vacacionar
además esto me hace pensar que el título
de paraíso lo estamos compartiendo con
los delincuentes internacionales que
hacen su fechoría por cualquier parte
del mundo y como han escuchado que hay
un país en el mismo trayecto del sol
pueden buscar una sombrita para
esconderse aquí y eso también preocupa
porque tienen la idea de que pueden
venir aquí y nadie los va a encontrar se
esconden en algún sitio esos son casos
que también conocemos todo esto me hizo
detenerme y pensar un poquito y
realmente me estaba quitando el sueño
como yo puedo ayudar a mi país cómo
puedo ayudar a mi gente si yo lo que soy
es un comunicador
yo hablo en televisión hablo en radio a
veces salgo en una película pero en
ningún momento yo pensé hacer vida
política no entonces que yo puedo hacer
que hago que tengo en mis manos
disponible y antes del picar de un ojo
señores junto a un guionista amigo
comenzamos a hacer vídeos de un minuto
usando la sátira y el humor para reírnos
de las cosas absurdas que vemos en la
política no solamente aquí sino en toda
latinoamérica y son absurdas de verdad
uno se pone a pensar gobiernos por
ejemplo gastando miles de millones en
cosas innecesarias o sin sentido
y la población siendo víctima de
precariedad es por falta de fondos
con estos vídeos yo pretendía aprovechar
mi pasión mis conocimientos mis redes
sociales para conectar con mi gente
desde lejos y de repente lo que comenzó
con estos vídeos de un minuto se ha
convertido un programa de 15 minutos
tres veces cada siete días con 116 mil
seguidores en youtube 76 mil en
instagram y sobrepasando las 11 millones
de vistas de reproducciones en dos años
esto es importante lamentablemente los
medios de comunicación tradicionales a
mi entender nos han fallado porque
porque la gran mayoría ha perdido la
objetividad o responden a intereses
políticos o grupos empresariales muy
grandes y por esta razón en todo el
planeta la gente se ha volcado a redes
sociales para
buscar la verdad detrás de esos casos
que se exponen y mi país no ha sido la
excepción
y así las redes sociales
esas mismas de la que yo le hablé al
principio esas donde estamos colgando un
self y para buscar esos likes en
instagram y facebook ahora también se
han convertido en el mejor vehículo para
la libertad de expresión que por cierto
la carta magna de república dominicana
habla en el artículo número 49 y les voy
a pedir que pasen por ahí un día de esto
para que lean lo que dice es a veces no
nos damos cuenta pero el internet está
ardiendo constantemente de un
intercambio de ideas entre personas de
todo el mundo y por esto gracias a dios
por el internet
las redes sociales son un instrumento
muy poderoso vamos a imaginar un
momentito cómo que esto es un
instrumento de justicia social para
crear conciencia pensemos por ejemplo en
el movimiento ice bucket pensemos en el
break back children and rolls en nigeria
las protestas en venezuela el terremoto
en nepal las inundaciones en mi amar
pensemos también en la fuerza mundial
que tiene el movimiento hoy en día mito
que comenzó con unas mujeres que estaban
compartiendo sus historias de abuso
sexual con esta etiqueta y que se
popularizó cuando la estrella de
televisión norteamericana de los años 80
que estaba en el género de la comedia
alyssa milano quien ayudó a convertirlo
en un movimiento internacional porque
ella también contó su historia
este movimiento señores a través de
internet utilizando un hashtag ha
logrado que agresores sexuales sean
condenados que se hayan generado cambios
en el lugar de trabajo y ha desatado un
diálogo internacional sobre un problema
sistémico como lo es el abuso sexual
todo esto porque alguien compartió su
historia por internet
si alguien tiene dudas sobre el alcance
y el poder de las redes sociales solo
debe recordar que tenemos líderes nos es
llamarles líderes pero líderes mundiales
que prefieren colocar un tweet en vez de
sentarse con
y toda una gama de periodistas a que le
hagan preguntas todos sabemos de quién
estoy hablando tenemos países además
coqueteando conflictos internacionales a
través de twitter esto es demasiado
poder para un pajarito azul piénsenlo
las generaciones pasadas impulsaban los
cambios con guerras con armas y hoy en
día tenemos la oportunidad de cambiar el
mundo con un solo tweet si la pluma es
más poderosa que la espada
entonces el empoderamiento social es más
fuerte que cualquier ejército
un instrumento para lograr un cambio
global se encuentra justo en las manos
de cada uno de nosotros y estos señores
hoy en día lo podemos catalogar como la
definición de poder
ahora pregúntense cuál es el mensaje ya
que tenemos este aparato en nuestras
manos cuál es el mensaje que nosotros
todos aquí queremos compartir que
queremos lograr lo curioso de todo esto
que le estoy contando es que me he
topado con personas de gran poder
adquisitivo y otras de pocos recursos
los más necesitados que me mencionan el
proyecto que hemos empezado y me dicen
lo mucho que se entretienen y se
identifican con lo que hacemos nosotros
pero por qué vamos a analizar es un
momentito que caja de pandora y que
hemos abierto nosotros
un día escuché yo estaba manejando una
planta y estaba pasando la radio y
escuché a un humorista que estaba en una
entrevista no recuerdo el nombre y por
eso pido disculpas porque me desmonte
del carro sin embargo se me quedó algo
que dijo ese señor y es que la forma la
forma más importante o la forma más
fácil de tu llamar la atención de
alguien es haciéndolo reír porque cuando
lo haces reír esa persona se olvida de
muchas cosas y se conecta directamente
con las emociones que tú le estás
transmitiendo transmitiendo y el mensaje
que tú le estás pasando
eso
es importante porque le estás abriendo
la mente a esa persona para que te
escuche por lo menos que te escuche no
que te de acuerdo contigo pero que te
escuche que verdad tan verdad señores la
risa es un instrumento muy poderoso la
razón por la cual vídeos de comediante
por ejemplo jones river no va yo no le
vert son compartidos millones de veces
en redes sociales a nivel mundial
porque son temas reales los que están
tratando y profundos de manera
entretenida
y accesible para todo el mundo para
nosotros por ejemplo la risa ha sido el
instrumento más importante en una de las
plataformas más poderosas y alcanzables
por todos mundialmente no solo no sólo
local donde estés sino que pueden
acceder
mundialmente no son uno ni dos los
ejemplos por es de gente que nos envían
mensajes a nuestro inbox diciendo me reí
cantidad con lo que ustedes estaban
haciendo el otro día pero cuando se me
acabó la risa men me puse a pensar
y eso es lo que queríamos lograr ese era
nuestra nuestra misión hacer pensar a
nuestros seguidores abrirles los ojos
por lo menos para empezar una
conversación esta idea para conectarme
con mi tierra se ha convertido en todo
un vehículo de cambio se ha convertido
en algo mucho más grande que todos
nosotros lo que estamos en este equipo
no teníamos ni idea del impacto que iba
a lograr ni iba a tener pero se está
logrando y les voy a decir y no les voy
a negar que a veces
encuentro que el equipo y yo nos
sentimos un poco cabizbajos agotados
que queremos dejarlo todo porque es
mucho trabajo
pero cuando leemos los más de 5000
mensajes semanales que nosotros
recibimos a través de youtube por email
en instagram en facebook nos damos
cuenta que tenemos que seguir porque
esto es más grande que nosotros
tenemos que seguir diciendo la verdad
cueste lo que cueste no importa como nos
quieran amedrentar
que ha pasado a animar a la gente a
luchar por lo que siente justo en su
corazón qué bueno que el mensaje está
llegando y que todos lo hacemos con la
risa porque es que tenemos señores que
poner atención a lo que está ocurriendo
en nuestro alrededor en nuestro entorno
no podemos dejar que el problema nos
toque a la puerta para nosotros decir
hay un problema
un país en el mundo no importa donde que
ama la igualdad de la misma forma que
ama los likes en instagram y facebook
un mundo que desee la libertad más que
un happy hour una juventud que valore la
paz y la prosperidad más que el último
modelo de automóvil que salió o el
último guay de la moda todo el mundo
trabajando por un bien común por el
favor de algo grande así también lo
mencionó john lennon en su famosa
icónica canción y nadie
que tanto tanto tanto se pone
para ver si se le graba ese mensaje a la
gente
entonces abran los ojos miren a su
alrededor pongan atención a lo que está
ocurriendo en su entorno no importa
donde estén ustedes dónde se encuentren
geográficamente qué cambios quiere
queremos todos ver si pueden iniciar una
revolución con un simple teléfono
celular que todos tenemos aquí que
estamos esperando hasta cuándo es si no
es ahora cuándo
aquí en república dominicana nuestra
independencia apenas tiene 175 años
somos una nación joven cuando nos
comparamos con otros países yo creo que
es el momento perfecto para recordar el
sacrificio que nuestros padres de la
patria hicieron para que hoy nosotros
aquí en república dominicana
seamos libre de cualquier potencia
extranjera
y como nación joven que somos entonces
tenemos que saber que hay un trabajo por
hacer para poder dejarles a las próximas
generaciones un país digno de llamar un
paraíso
el mensaje que le quiero dejar con esto
es que comiencen ustedes mismos
por ustedes mismos con los que les
rodean las personas que están cerca de
ustedes su círculo en su escuela en
donde sea donde tienen los hijos los
demás padres en los vecinos va a hablar
a conversar no todo el mundo se va a
poner de acuerdo pero por lo menos
empezamos una conversación esos los que
están cerca de nosotros para una mejoría
colectiva no piensen en lo
insignificante que podría ser hablar con
10 personas
fulano o mengano mira que tocará esto
sino de los lejos que puede llegar ese
mensaje
porque con el tiempo esas cositas se
convierten en grandes cosas para
nosotros los dominicanos si esta isla
con toda su belleza hermosa es nuestra
herencia entonces los casos de
corrupción e impunidad también van a ser
parte de este patrimonio
yo me imagino que cuando a alguien
heredará una tierrita
no lo desecha
entonces eso es bueno que lo pensemos
yo prefiero mil veces que los títulos
que adornen mi presentación en cualquier
sitio sea sergio carlo actor comunicador
y dominicano orgulloso muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]